what do we know about what's happened at
hank lee common aisha it looks pretty
major doesn't it from the pictures we've
seen
absolutely well sorry fire and rescue
service have declared a major incident
over this as far as we understand the
fire is contained to hank lee common at
the moment you can see uh huge huge
clouds of smoke billowing from the area
and it's actually the second time it's
caught fire the same thing happened on
the same patch of land on wednesday that
affected four hectares of land and after
that initial fire was put out emergency
services did say that with warm
temperatures still expected ahead
and with extremely dry conditions they
were warning the public to take care to
avoid
avoid hosting barbecues near near the
area to avoid something like this
happening again but of course it has
happened as far as we understand uh
residential properties surrounding the
area haven't been affected yet but there
are concerns over
the wind which is well and truly blowing
you can see it is quite windy here
we've spoken to one local resident who
said that october farm
is a nearby farm and they are planning
to evacuate but the advice from
emergency services at the moment to
local residents is to keep windows and
doors closed to make sure pets stay
inside and to avoid going out into the
area because the smoke has well and
truly taken hold people have been
reported being able to see the smoke as
far as guildford on the m25 as well on
the drive up here i have to say you
could see the clouds of smoke from miles
and miles away so emergency services
will be working here to get the blaze
out and to get it under control
yeah and we can see it behind you there
over your shoulder what's uh going on uh
firefighters we understand is certainly
going to be there overnight and into
tomorrow uh
just how many people are around and what
have they been saying given this uh i
didn't know that that's that's
interesting this uh blew up originally
flared up on wednesday that affected as
you're saying four
hectares and we're led to believe it's
at least double that area today
absolutely and it is a
highly residential area small quaint
villages surrounding the area so far uh
from the locals we've spoken to that
there aren't major concerns that they
will have to evacuate but some are
making plans should that be the case so
it's really going to be a case of
keeping an eye on how the wind blows
whether it's going to fan the flames
whether fire services will be able to
keep it contained
in the area but like you said they're
going to be working throughout the day
potentially into the night potentially
into tomorrow
and all of this like i said caused by
the still warm temperatures and also the
extremely dry conditions as well leading
to just this flaring up yet again